this is a precautionary measure because  two nhs staff members did have allergic  reactions yesterday we don't know how  severe they were but just as a  precaution they're saying people should  not have the vaccine if they have  reacted  uh in the past to other vaccines  medicines or in indeed  food now it's it's not unusual for a for  a new vaccine like this to  to cause a problem um if you think about  other vaccines too there are some which  are not recommended  for people with with food allergies egg  for example  um is is used to to grow some brands of  the flu vaccine  uh so people are urged not to have those  and there are other instances too uh  where people are very cautious about  certain medicines so  not unusual and not a disaster but it  was interesting listening to  uh professor chris whissey saying that  uh it's possible that in in the months  to come we will have a choice of  of vaccines and that is a very nice  problem to have admissibly tell the  committee